hey guys Peter Brown is Sean McKenna is
here from PAX East 2014 one of the
highlights of the show here is the indie
mega booth where some of the greatest
indie games that frankly I've ever seen
are all on hand in one place yeah
there's a lot of really good stuff like
I think literally about a hundred indie
games are crammed into the small space
but if you navigate it successfully
you'll find some really really really
cool stuff yes starting with a little
game called hyper light drifter now this
is probably the one game that if you
could pick a sort of like most
talked-about indie game of show this
year only gonna be this one it's at
least the one whose line has swelled up
the most it's just gorgeous visually
stunning type of game where you don't
really even need to play it to be
floored by it but if you do actually
play it what's it like oh it's so easy
to appreciate the the movement of your
character so this it's almost like a
top-down action game and essentially
you're this this little sprightly guy
and yes he's a sprite but yeah he moves
really fast and he's got a few different
abilities and essentially you're facing
off enemies it sounds really generic but
really you're allowed to you know zip to
and fro it's a 2d game that's like top
down but there's verticality involved
somehow they've worked that in there and
it's this really atmospheric world that
you're battling there's no text there's
no dialogue yeah lots of atmosphere and
lots of really engaging action as well
yeah I mean the developer made sure to
point out that they're not trying to
explain anything to you you just kind of
in this crazy gorgeous ethereal world
and you're just navigating it and
fighting enemies really I mean it's a
hack-and-slash game right is that how
you describe it yeah but it feels really
nice and the world is is is really
compelling cuz you're not really sure
what's going on but there's a lot of
little visual cues to kind of lead you
along the way but of course there are
many other games yes ah such as
roundabouts roundabouts Pacifica what
about so you didn't get a chance to play
this one no but I've seen it before and
I have a really good understanding of
what it is because I played a lot of
Crazy Taxi yes yeah so it once you
explained fortunately I did get a chance
to play this one and it yeah Crazy Taxi
is definitely the closest touchstone I
would compare it to it's basically like
an absurdist magical realism 1970s Crazy
Taxi if the wheel was like stuck in one
position yes the entire time so it's
kind of like it follows in the same line
as a game like
surgeon simulator where it has an
intentionally kind of like almost
awkward kind of control scheme right at
its core which is the fact that you are
driving a big limousine that's always
turning to the right yeah so you're
constantly just like driving in circles
trying not to hit with the car yeah you
try not to hit other cars and it's an
open world so you're navigating through
streets and side streets and alleys
sometimes and you basically you run
around you pick up customers when you
pick them up it triggers these really
funny full motion video cutscenes yeah
FMV as the kids call them right um yeah
and it's just it's really fun like the
the whole spinning mechanic is we're
really weird for like the first few
minutes but then you pick it up and you
get used to it and it's just a fun crazy
way of navigating an open world so fun
is great yes what else I love dark
morose games that really make you
question the decisions you make in life
yes such as gods will be watching yeah
which is an adventure game through and
through
well it's a point and click game with
little vignettes right and so you
basically are presented with these
scenarios where the people's lives sort
of hang in the balance of your decisions
and it's it's not so much a binary
system where you say okay you live and
you die you're basically trying to keep
everyone alive but you have the option
to kill people if it'll benefit the
group yes yeah so there are different
like vignettes they were showing on
different days
we both did the survival one yes right
okay so basically like in this case you
and a group of survivors are on this
really harsh alien planet and you're all
just kind of hanging around the campfire
and you have really limited supplies
morale is a huge issue and you are the
guy in charge and you make the decisions
of what you do and you only have like I
think about five or so actions within a
particular day right yeah and as it
shifts you know from night to the
following morning the results of your
actions you know your view you're told
like okay well you didn't really give
John the pep talk he needed or you
didn't give Melissa the cure to the
virus that's permeating the world and
now she's dead and John ran off into the
woods like a madman and probably isn't
going to come back yeah and John was the
guy who could create the cure for the
virus yes no everyone could succumb to
this
yeah it's just one of those games where
you just constantly wracked with guilt
over the decisions that you made but you
carry on because there's still hope for
survival you have the best intentions
but ultimately you feel like a piece of
[ __ ] exactly and finally another dart
game that's not quite as morose right
yeah just dark in general is a game
called below yeah this is from capybara
games it was exclusive to Xbox one for a
point time they recently announced a
steam release which i think is wonderful
yeah because this game it presents a a
really large landscape and you're a
really tiny character and it's sort of
driving home the theory that you're
incredibly isolated and incredibly
fragile compared to you know the
environment around you yes absolutely
now like hyper light drifter it's also a
game with no HUD elements you have no
explanation you just you're on this
Beach and you kind of press forward and
you discover like this cave and you're
just descending through it and they told
me that Dark Souls was a huge
inspiration they have the whole bonfire
system yeah seems like rivers from that
spelunky was a huge inspiration with a
randomly generated world and it's tough
as nails it's really really gorgeous
just atmospheric so there you have it
that's a light sampling there's so many
more yeah there's a whole lot more and
in fact we're gonna be covering them on
gamespot comp oh yeah so pay attention
to games watch comm we've got a little
PAX East banner up on the top click on
that to find more coverage of any games
and great triple-a stuff from the show
floor it's again - Sean McGuinness and
Peter Brown thanks for watching